this is it this is the iPhone 10's max
this is in the beautiful gold version
and holding this up next to my previous
version of the iPhone 10 you guys can
see the size is so much bigger and the
color is it's the most perfect gold
color that I could have ever asked for
at the beginning I was like I really
want a nice rose gold and this is it and
I can't wait to go see the watch too but
you guys can see the size difference
here it is I mean is displayed
so good just getting back to my hotel
from the Apple event if you guys watched
it online I'm sure you already know
everything that was announced but today
I want to go through some of the
highlights last year was the first event
they'd ever held at the Steve Jobs
theater when they launched the iPhone 10
and this was the second year thank you I
appreciate it guys he just called me the
mother of YouTube this is exciting
little doesn't know I'm probably the
grandmother at this point it is such a
beautiful theater it really does embody
everything that Apple represents it's
just so incredible to see in person so
as soon as I got there I ran into a
bunch of my youtuber friends so it's
always great to see them with these
events these techy youtubers as a movie
hardest working people on this platform
the best part about this is Marc has
brought his entire iMac I thought you
were joking I had to so it takes a long
time to render these videos and what
better way to speed that up then a
little extra horsepower anyway let's go
briefly through some of the highlights
they announced three new phones today
there's the iPhone 10s the iPhone 10s
Macs and the iPhone 10 are the iPhone 10
art comes in six different colors and it
was really surprised at how vibrant
these colors were some of the leaks and
the rumors that we had seen they were
kind of like these dog down colors but
when you see these in person and if you
can see here you're some b-roll that I
shot of them in they're really really
beautiful if I had to pick I would
probably go for the coral one the 10r
isn't going to be available immediately
if those will be available later in
October so what's great is a starting
price for these are 749 will come in a
64 128 and 256 gig model now why this
phone is less expensive than the 10s and
the tennis max is because first of all
the screen is LCD not OLED like the 10s
and 10's max and the band around it is
aluminum instead of stainless steel the
10 are also only has one camera as
opposed to two like the 10s and 10's max
but it still has the capability to give
you portrait mode photos front and back
now while the 10r is pretty awesome a
great price point to this 10s and 10's
max Wow this phone looks so good in the
new gold color it is the gold that I
have always wanted one of the things I
feel like in the past they've called
their phones gold they've called them
rose gold they've either been not gold
enough or too pink but this color so it
actually matched this is a row
gold bracelet that I have and this gold
almost matches that gold perfectly so
the 10s comes in two sizes like I said
there's the tennis the tennis max the
10s max is a 6.5 inch OLED and the S
just regular no max I wish they would
have called it mini maybe there will be
a 10s mini it'll be even smaller
sidetracked 10s five point eight inch
OLED HD are super Retina displays these
things look super crisp but one of the
things I thought was interesting even
just holding up the 10 R and the 10s max
the LCD display in the 10 are still
looks really really good so this is
gonna make it really difficult for
people to decide of which phone and do I
want because the 10 are still has so
many capabilities that you're going to
want but yet that price point is just so
good because the 10s and 10's max are a
little bit more expensive and by a
little bit I mean a lot because if you
want to be 512 maxed out 10s max maxed
out oh gosh mm-hmm the 512 configuration
is 1449 I just had to look at it just to
make sure that's a lot obviously most
people are probably not going to need
the 512 gigs of storage I make a lot of
youtube videos I transfer so much
footage onto my phone I do a lot of
editing I do a lot of things on my phone
and I haven't even filled up this phone
yet let's just double check and see how
much storage I actually have left I've
only used 96 gigs of my 256 gigs used
which is kind of crazy because I do put
a lot of stuff on my phone so that's
kind of shocking that leads me to
believe that most people are not going
to need a 512 giggle because the 256
will run you at 12:49 and the base model
64 is $10.99 if you opt for just the 10s
which is the smaller version that starts
at 999 the 256 is 11:49 and the 512 is
1349 these come in three colors the gold
the silver and the space grace so both
the silver and the Space Gray look
almost identical to the previous
versions of the ten but this gold I just
can't stress enough how beautiful it is
it is such a great color I'm also
extremely excited because the gold
matches the new gold Apple watch too if
you decide to do
nice matching combo they finally match
because this white I mean it sort of
does but this is like a mirrored finish
whereas this is kind of not as
reflective but these golds match
perfectly much like the iPhone 10 it
also has dual cameras both of the back
cameras are 12 megapixel whereas the
front in 7 megapixels but you can now
shoot 1080 60 frames a second on your
front facing camera which is really
really cool one of my favorite camera
features is this adjustable aperture so
what that means is you can adjust the
background blur after you take a photo
as you can see in this little demo you
can turn it up turn it down so depending
upon your creative choice you don't have
to worry about if the photo is perfect
when you took it you can adjust things
afterwards adds a new age fold Bionic
chip which means processes will be much
much faster they say that you can open
apps 30% faster than the 2017 iPhones I
love this photo that they kept using for
the demos we saw this so many times
throughout this entire event normally
most of the photos that you take like
this like something is not gonna be
right either the background is gonna be
completely blown out because it's super
bright or you're gonna completely lose
your subject because it's gonna be way
too contrasted I'm just wondering how
many takes did it take them to get this
shot either way it's incredible and I
cannot wait to get my hands on this
thing to be able to really test out the
photos they also showed some really fun
video demos and the bike ones
specifically they showed in the event I
got to see it on the actual phone that
video was shot on the iPhone and it also
records stereos
so as the bikes were kind of like
cruising past the stereo on the iPhone
actually picked that up they also
announced dual sim support this is gonna
be kind of interesting for people that
travel especially if you travel a lot
internationally they're gonna have an e
sim and then a regular sim card so I'm
not a hundred percent sure how that is
all going to work but that is something
that I think if you do travel a lot it's
gonna be something that you're
definitely gonna want it's now
water-resistant up to two meters and for
30 minutes so that now gives an IP 68
water-resistant rating they also
mentioned that it has been tested
against other types of liquids not just
clean water but like salt water they
mentioned beer and I think they might
have said coffee I'm not sure but I know
I've definitely tested out my iPhone pet
and coffee and you know what it's it's
fine it's still here this is the only
foam that I have never shattered out of
all of the phones that I've ever owned
this iPhone 10
has made it and it actually looks really
good although I have a very small little
chip just got this two days ago when we
were flying drones I had set the
controller down and it just kind of just
took a little slip and it hit around
it's so so small but I can't believe
that that is the only small piece of
damage that I have done to this phone so
considering this is the only iPhone that
I've never shattered this is really
great news because the new iPhone is
even more durable they said that the
glass on the front and the back is more
resistant than the previous version I
still can't stop thinking about how
excited I am to try out some of the new
video features because all of the video
that they shot and showed in the demo
looked incredible they showed a bunch of
slides about how the smart HDR works
because of the faster processor they're
able to take more photos in such a short
amount of time so they're able to pull
out the highlights the lowlights the
shadows everything that you would want
in a photo and kind of merge it all into
one and then magically a beautiful
perfect photo appears and I'll tell you
what there's so many times that my
sister and I will go out to shoot some
photos or video and we have expensive
lenses and cameras and half the time I'm
like just take them just take a picture
on your phone just take it on the phone
it adds up just looking better and it's
instant we haven't even talked about the
Apple watch yet series 4 was announced
today and I'll tell you what I am so
excited for watching was 5 I have yet to
try the beta but one of the things that
I'm most excited about other than the
walkie talkie feature is that you can
now track yoga and hiking and those are
pretty much two of my favorite fitness
activities and I've never actually been
able to accurately track those before
but now we can
I never realized before that the edges
of this Apple watch are square I mean
obviously I realized it but I didn't
realize how prominent it was until
holding it next to the new Apple watch
they now increase the screen size they
have rounded edges that go so much
closer to the watch face
and 40 millimeters and you guys can see
them besides differences pretty
significant and it definitely feel much
heavier than the previous version so
here is my ceramic 38 millimeter and up
next to here it looks so good so if you
have small wrists
I definitely wouldn't recommend getting
the bigger version it is well actually
it looks incredible
but I think that the smaller one might
fit better I am also left-handed that's
why I put my watch on the other hand
[Music]
they said the overall surface space of
the Apple watch is smaller but yet the
size is a little tall a little bit wider
but it's thinner and it's also great
news because you can still use all of
the previous versions of Apple watch
bands so you won't have to upgrade
unless you're like me it went from the
42 millimeter the 38 and then you had to
get all new watch bands they also have
some new Apple watch faces they have
water fire they have liquid metal they
also have some new breathing sequences
so if you are a fan of the breathing app
they have watch faces now to match they
also have these really advanced
complications too so if you want to add
more data which it's super overwhelming
when you first look at it but I feel
like this is probably the watch face
that I would want to set up if I wanted
to have all of the information that I
could ever possibly need it's there it
now has haptic feedback in the digital
crown so if you're scrolling through
photos or whatever it is that you're
scrolling through it'll be giving you
the appropriate haptic feedback as you
turn the dial another highlight for me
on the new Apple watch is the new heart
rate monitoring features before they
would tell you if your heart rate was
too high but they also have something
now that will tell you if your heart
rate is too low it will also look for
irregular heart rhythms so if there is
some sort of thing going on that you
can't really see your Apple watch will
see it before you will even know about
it the digital crown will also be able
to give you an ECG reading so using the
ECG app you just place your finger right
here on the crown and you hold it for 30
seconds this will be one of the first
times that an ECG device will be
available to consumers just over the
counter usually I feel like that's
something that doctors will have to
prescribe to you or it's super expensive
it'll then take that data send it to
your phone you can then email
send it to your doctors text message it
to your friends whatever it is that you
want to do with it you will have that
information another feature that ended
up just being thick most craziest memes
all over Twitter but this is fall
detection so the Apple watch will now be
able to detect if you've had a fall and
if you don't report back and say that
you're ok with in a minute and your
watch is completely still it'll then
contact your emergency contacts and will
call for help so I think that's
something that's really important and
yeah I know a lot of people are making
jokes about it but I think for elderly
people even for me who knows I'm always
hiking and doing crazy things and I find
myself in situations where yeah it could
be potentially dangerous and I just feel
like this watch has already saved so
many people's lives alerting them of
when they potentially are having a heart
attack but this is just something else
that is seemingly a very small thing but
I feel like after this is implemented
and people start wearing this and using
it and actually having to unfortunately
put it to the test I think that it will
save lives or at least prevent some
serious injuries so that's something
that I'm excited to test out I'm
actually a really good fake caller is
that is that a talent a skill definitely
is because I used to trip and fall in
high school all the time and I would get
in so much trouble I didn't get in
trouble at first but then they realized
that I was doing it over and over again
and not hurting myself and it just
turned into a whole joke that's a whole
nother story I'm really good at falling
although I'm a lot older now so I
probably will hurt myself at least I'll
know if I have an injury I could tell my
watch yes I need help they also moved
the speaker in the microphone to
opposite sides on the Apple watch so the
microphone is now placed by the digital
crown and the speaker is on the opposite
side and the speakers are now 50% louder
another highlight which is not really
that big of a highlight but for me it is
the home pod will now finally get an
update and you'll be able to add
multiple timers I know I'm sure with
that is just a few highlights here from
the Apple event I had such a great time
and I hope that you guys enjoyed this
video I'm sure a bunch of my friends
will also have amazing Apple content out
very very soon as you guys know it's
Apple season it's gaming season there's
gonna be so much fun stuff coming out
and I look forward to checking it out
with you you guys haven't already
subscribed to my channel make sure you
do so by hitting subscribe and be sure
to hit the bell looks like this and
you'll be notified when I
good videos you can also follow me
everywhere else on social as iJustine
and definitely leave me some comments
because I really love hearing from you
guys and I love hearing what you
actually think of the events which
phones are you gonna get which color is
your favorite which advil watch do you
like which phone do you have currently
are you not an Apple fan do you have an
Android all of these questions you can
answer below I'll see you guys later bye
we're now inside the Steve Jobs theater
it is such a beautiful theater it's so
crazy because no one can really figure
out how is this thing standing
finally
what is up I just think that's a lot for
Dubai
[Music]